[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
ich glaube dass wir das kürzeste video
was ich jemals auf diesem kanal
hochgeladen habe es gibt jetzt nämlich
ein blitzschnelles rezept für ein
fruchteis was ihr wirklich sofort zu
bereiten könnte superlecker und vor
allem für mich als mama ist immer ganz
wichtig nur im sommer wollen die kinder
oft eisessen und da kommt natürlich auch
vor dass wir jeden tag eis essen und
vielleicht auch zweimal am tag und das
finde ich auch völlig okay solange man
es nicht übertreibt und daher habe ich
mir das wirklich angewöhnt das eis auch
selber zu machen weil ich den
zuckergehalt bestimmen kann ich kann
bestimmen ob ich überhaupt
industriezucker verwende oder nicht und
ich kann einfach bestimmen was drinnen
ist dieses eis ist jetzt im fruchteis
werde ich zu bereiten ihr könnt auch
super vegan vorbereiten und die braucht
wirklich nur vier zutaten und fünf
minuten ihrer lebenszeit und es ist ein
ice komplett um industriezucker ich
verwende dafür 300 kamen die vorne
früchte habe ich einfach eine schöne
bunte mischung zwei reife bananen zum
süßen 100 gramm joghurt und etwas
vanille extrakt vanille extrakt ist
natürlich nur optional ihr könnt auch
ein bisschen zitronen ab dazu geben aber
das verfahren hat einfach das ganze und
geht so ein bisschen nochmal den
geschmack ich hab hier einfach alle
reste an früchten genommen die ich so
gefunden habe blaubeeren himbeeren
kirschen erdbeeren gehen auch ganz gut
und ich habe hier zwei fleißige
helferinnen wie heute das eis zu beraten
werden samira auf kreta hallo jetzt weiß
gießen freude aufs eis super also alles
was wir brauchen ist im prinzip ein
mixer oder einem stabmixer kommen wieder
hoch
mit uns
geht oder um ihr könnt mir die bananen
schon mal schälen und rhein geben wie
früher wie in diesem video ja so geht es
natürlich auch quatsch ja die bananen
die dürfen wirklich schön süß und reif
sein also gerne außen auch schon braun
gefleckt was ich auch immer ganz gerne
mache ist dass die bananen wenn sie
schon überreif sind einfach schön
dann habe ich praktisch da auch schon
mal die kalte komponente so der joghurt
darf auch rein und schön aus köpfen und
bei den bären einfach benutzen was
schmeckt ob jetzt erdbeereis himbeereis
kirschen aprikosen eis ist völlig egal
oder mango orange und wenn ihre stimme
sei wichtig auf und wenn ihr praktisch
sagt ich habe keine gefrorenen früchten
im tier frische früchte friert sie ein
witziger form sind und ihr könnt dann
das eis zu bereiten
kreta wenn du möchtest kommst du dran
also soll ich dir helfen kann ich halte
ja das ist echt ein bisschen hoch für
euch
obwohl jetzt nix
[Musik]
und jetzt ist das eis schon fertig je
nachdem welche früchte verwendet sollte
natürlich der banane mehr oder weniger
nehmen also erdbeeren sie eigentlich
immer schön süß himmel sind eher sauer
und kirchen auch das heißt wir probieren
einfach und verfeinern nach eurem
geschmack des ice einfach weiter und ich
habe jetzt hier keine gefrorenen bananen
benutzt das heißt es etwas softer ich
könnte jetzt noch mal kurz für eine
stunde einfrieren wenn ihr gefordert
bananen habt können das auch wirklich
sofort essen aber so ist es wo er wird
uns oft auch gut ok bewertet mal das eis
ich hole so lange strecke ist eure
punktzahl
ja ja
der goldene ball ich habe den goldenen
ball
ich hatte jetzt hier diese schüssel auch
bereits im gefrierfach
das heißt dies auch schön kalt also
entweder sehr wir sind sofort aus
bechern aus gläsern oder wie auch immer
die kinder und erwachsene können sofort
essen oder ihr fritz nochmals ein damit
einfach nur etwas festere konsistenz
bekommt
ich würde sagen wir freuen uns ein da
können wir euch so kugel machen hoppla
richter gekleckert
ja weil es gleich aus der waffe
[Musik]
vielleicht dieser mini waffen die haben
vielleicht drücken weil ich glaube es
kommt nämlich keine also ich fress 1
und dann wird bei uns gegessen das weiß
ich gar nicht so weit das video schon
beenden weil ist nicht fertig wir sehen
uns
jetzt könnte abschreckend nicht alleine
mit seiner freundin
kaum gibt es eis weg kommt angerannt
hallo hallo ich bin jetzt etwas neidisch
auf samira schöne umarmung der mais
gemacht sie trifft gleich probieren noch
ein bisschen muss es abkühlen ok kannst
du dich gedulden
ich glaube schon
kannst du schon mal hände waschen und
zeig mir mal was dir weh getan hat
[Musik]
doch eins ist bereits mädels seid ihr
bereit
also dann schnappt euch eine kugel eis
frucht reif und probiert mal ist halt ne
eis was man praktisch sofort servieren
sollte wir hatten jetzt auch noch mal im
gefrierschrank damit es besser wird
aber ihr seht schon es wird natürlich
dann ziemlich fest wenn man mixt ist
kommt ganz groß ins gefrierfach und dann
ist ganz sofort zur komplett ohne
emulgatoren ohne konservierungsstoffe
ohne farbstoffe ohne künstlichen zucker
einfach ein leckeres buch da ist findet
ihr mit den kleinen mini erdbeeren und
himbeeren
okay da hat mal wieder sind super aber
ist okay solltet ihr auf jeden fall mal
ausprobieren und vor allem könnt ihr die
farbe definieren also wir haben ja jetzt
bereit werden ob mit drin
das heißt ist ein bisschen dunkleres
wenn ihr nur himbeeren verwendet ist es
bis im frühjahr bei kirschen ist weinrot
strichcode also richtig richtig gut
probiert gerne mal aus postet euer foto
von eurem eis und dann sehen wir sie da
beim nächsten mal
und kinder sind begeistert und die
ella's wahrscheinlich draußen gespielt
mit dem wasser
dann kriegt sie jetzt noch nie haben die
mit
[Musik]